hey everybody it's Jimmy with bright
insight today I'm going to talk to you
about the Great Sphinx and how what we
were taught in school and what they are
still teaching in school today is
inaccurate basically they say that the
Sphinx is 4,500 years old however
significant evidence determined by more
than 200 professional geologists from
around the world have determined that
the encasing of the Sphinx the bedrock
limestone has significant evidence of
water erosion well why is this important
well the last time the Nile Delta had
significant rainfall was approximately
nine thousand years ago and as you can
see here from these photos yes there is
evidence of wind erosion on the Sphinx
wind and sand erosion this we can see
however the enclosure of the Sphinx
itself has absolute definitive evidence
of water and rain erosion and guys the
evidence is here for you to see and you
can make your own judgments yourself
well you might be asking why if there
was evidence that it's far older than
what we're being told why would it be
why would someone say otherwise
well that's a whole other video on
itself and there was so much evidence
and information out there about this
subject that I'm going to hold off on it
and I want to just show you in this
video clear evidence that you can see
with your own eyes that this that there
is significant water erosion so if
there's significant water erosion when
could that have happened
well the Nile Delta area has not got
more than an inch of rainfall for
thousands of years and that there's
evidence that the last time that area
had significant rainfall was literally
more than 9,000 years ago and some
sources say even more than that wake up
people that's more than twice as old as
the Sphinx is being told taught in
school today in public and at the
university level look at these photos
look I can break it down where you see
water erosion and where you see wind
erosion look at the comparison here
where you can see as it's outlined and
by the way thank you for the i source
these photos off google images i'm using
them for you know educational purposes
here so thank you to everybody who has
done the research what i'm doing here
today is i'm synthesizing and putting
together the information for people to
see because the information on full
about the history of human civilization
is far more complicated than what we
were taught in school and what is being
taught today and when you control the
past you control the present and the
future and that is why this is important
but take a look at these photos here you
can see clear evidence where I've
compared side by side wind verse water
erosion look at these photos limestone
water erosion wind erosion here's
another picture of more wind erosion now
here's a picture of limestone water
erosion and compare it next to this
gentleman that is standing inside with
the enclosure of the Sphinx now look at
the next photo two pictures of water
erosion and limestone water erosion
there it is
when you piece it together guys it's
fair to say that it's a two-fold answer
that yes there is some wind erosion and
there is rain erosion however if there's
rain or erosion as you can clearly see
here and as like I said 200 professional
geologists from around the world have
stated then you have to ask start asking
yourself some questions like how old is
the Sphinx well guys there are
significant evidence that human
civilization is far older than what we
were ever taught and maybe potentially
by tens of thousands of years
well guys I'm Jimmy this is bright
insight I'm making more videos I'm a new
Channel and there's far more videos to
come like and subscribe if you'd like
what I have to say and help me spread
the message be blessed all